كان فيها المنتخب الارجنتيني حامل لقب كاس
العالم 20 22 يضيء ليل العاصمه
الارجنتينيه
الى قسمين على يمين الشاشه هذه الحافله
التي تقل اعضاء المنتخب الارجنتيني وعلى
اليسار وتابع الشارع هذا على فكره الشارع
احد شوارع العاصمه
الارجنتينيه اقتضادا
من طريق المطار ليفصل بالعاصمه واحياؤها
هذا الشارع رغم ان الساعه متاخره جدا
الثالثه بعد منتصف الليل ثلاثه ونصف
تقريبا
احتفالات ستكون على مدار عام استقبال
الاقطار استقبال جماهيري غفير نشاهده في
العاصمه الارجنتينيه لوصول
المنتخب الارجنتيني حامل لقب المونديال
الى بلاده ولان الكره ليست مساله رياضه
فقط الكره هي انسان الكره هي وحده هي شعور
هي موقف بين البشر وهي وطنيه حين يشعر كل
افراد البلد والمواطنين بانهم تحت اسم
واحد اسم بلدها ومنتخب بلادهم يشعرون
بالفخر يتحدون مجددا حتى نحن العرب اتحدنا
مجددا بعد ان شعرنا بان المنتخبات العربيه
تمثلها وان كنا من جنسيات مختلفه فوز
الثالث في تاريخ الارجنتين يعني صبرهم
طاليا نادين من عام 1986 هما ينتظروا
اللحظه التاريخيه بعد كل بطوله لكاس
العالم تحققت في قطر وحصل للمنتخب
الارجنتيني على اللقب للمره الثالثه في
تاريخه وقادر لقب الاسطوره ميسي حاملا كاس
العالم واصلا اليوم الى الارجنتين وعلى
فكره ميسي يعتبر رغم انه حصل على كثير من
الجوائز وعمل جاهدا لكي يحصل على اللقب
ولكن الحظ حالفه لكي يخطر مسيرته وهو في
القمه وهو في يعني هو حظي بهذا الشرف بشرف
التشويش في اخر مونديال له رغم انه ما
زالت المعلومات متضاربه حتى الان ان كان
سيكمل مسيرته الرياضيه لكن المونديال لك
الاخر
لوصول طائره المنتخب الارجنتيني وخرج منها
ميسي اول الوصلين رافعا كاس العالم الكاس
العالم الذي انتظر جميع محبي ميسي ان يحصل
عليه اخيرا وان يرفعه قبل همم يعني اخر
مونديال وكان العالم يقول بانه فوز منتخب
ميسي على فرنسا يعني كانت هي الحقائق وكان
ميسي يعامل هذا الكاس وكانه احد ابنائه
يقبله كل لحظات يحضنه همم
ميسي يعني حقق حلمه في ارض عربيه
مونديال 20 30 لفوز
بالمونديال هو الثالث لها تاريخيا وصول
المنتخب اليوم وصول الابطال حاملا كاس
العالم الى بيونس ايرس هذا الحضور
الجماهيري حضور الشعب الغفير بانتظار
ابالهم منتخب الارجنتين ونشير ايضا بان
كاس العالم الذي اقيم في دوله خليجيه هو
ابرز هذه الدول على الخارطه وضع العالم
العربي ودول الخليج اكثر فاكثر في خارطه
العالم بعد ان كانت
المواطنين والجماهير في بلدان بعيده كل
البعد عنا لا تعرف هذه المنطقه لا تعرف
عاداتها لا تعرف ثقافاتها لكن اليوم من
خلال هذه المونديال تعرفت اكثر واحترمت
هذه الثقافه واعجبت بها واشيبت بها اليوم
العالم اجمع يعرف دول الخليج من خلال
احتفاليات وما حصل على طوال شهر كامل
ثالثه اليوم فجرا بتوقيت بيسارنس بتوقيت
الارجنتيني وهذا الحضور الشعبي الغفير
وهذا الانتظار الشعب الكبير للابطال
الكبار
ما زال الموكب يسير بكل شموخ وكل فرح حتى
ان هذه الاحتفالات ستتواصل مع احتفالات
اعياد الميلاد بعد حوالي كم يوم وايضا مع
احتفالات نهايه هذا العام سيكون هناك
تواصل للاحتفالات احتفالات مليونيه كما
وصفت بعناوين الصحف التي تداولت ما هو
جدول اعمال احتفاليه المنتخب الارجنتيني
سواء كان وينوس وايضا في مدن الارجنتينيا
مختلفه اذا الارجنتين تحصل على كاس العالم
للمره الثالثه في تاريخها الاسطوره ميسي
افضل هداف للارجنتين في تاريخ كاس العالم
اول لاعب في تاريخ الممتاز يسجل في جميع
ادوار البطوله لاعب الحائز على السبعه كره
ذهبيه سبع مرات حاصل على الكره الذهبيه
اكمل اكتساح الجوائز الاسطوره ميسي بحصوله
على كاس العالم بعد ان حصل سابقا على
الكره الذهبيه والحذاء الذهبي اليوم يصل
يا بلدي الارجنتين وهو رافعا كاس العالم
لاول مره في تاريخه وللمره الثالثه في
تاريخ الارجنتين
دائما فوز وما اجمل طعم الانتصار هذه
الفرحه هي ليست فرحه فرديه هي فرحه تمثل
وطن تمثل افراد هؤلاء الافراد عملوا معا
في كافه مباريات كاس العالم
كفريق واحد وكعضو واحد لان يد واحده لا
تصفق كما يقال فهم يعملون بجهد متواصل ولا
يعملون بشكل فردي وهذا كان لافتا من خلال
لعب بهم في مباريات كاس العالم ودائما
مبروك لارجنتين هذا التاريخ
كبطاله لكاس العالم 2022 في قطر تبقى عيون
على هذه اللحظات تاريخيه